hey thanks Alan um so various people
came up to me during coffee break and
said they were really tired and sleepy
I'm not sure if I should like make this
really animate it to keep you all awake
or if I should do it very low key so you
can just snooze away um but let's see
what happens um to help you will sleep
I'm gonna start off by explaining some
stuff that you already probably know a
lot of the work on dichotomies has been
on things related Tom a morphism so I'm
going to start about start off by
talking about homomorphisms firstly in a
way that you'll completely recognize and
then in a slightly different way that
will lead on to the more general
partitions of graphs that I'm going to
be considering so we're used to thinking
of a whole morphism arm from a graph G
to a graph H being a function from the
vertices of G to the vertices of age um
such that any edge G must get mapped to
an agent H so for example if we look
hurt this edge here we see that one end
gets mapped to hear the other end gets
mapped to here and we've met an edge to
an edge that's the normal definition ER
homomorphisms and notice that we don't
care what happens to non edges so for
example well we can probably find a non
edge that's been mapped to an edge here
we go here's one and there's no edge
between these two vertices but they get
mapped across to these two vertices
which are adjacent so we don't really
care what happens to knowledge
okay i'm going to look at homomorphisms
in a slightly different way I'm going to
consider a homomorphism from a graph G
to a graph H to be a partition of the
vertex set of graph G so each part of
this partition is going to be labeled
with a vertex of h and I'm going to
insist that if I've got a partition
labeled with vertex U and a partition
labeled with vertex V if there's no edge
between those vertices in h I'm not
going to be allowed to have any edges
between any vertex and map in the part
labeled with you and any vertex in the
part labeled with P also if I've got two
vertices in the same partition in the
same part of the partition I'm not going
to allow any edge between those two
vertices unless there's a self loop on
the corresponding vertex of age so
instead of looking at a map from
vertices two vertices like this I'm
going to consider a partition so I've
partitioned into these blue sets here
each of these parts of the partition for
example this one here is associated with
a single vertex over in h I suppose I
could have added an empty part here
that's associated with the h and you'll
see for example but there are no edges
within this part or within this part
because neither of these two vertices
have self loops on them and you'll
notice that for example there is no edge
between this part and this part
I should look up to so here we have two
vertices of age that aren't adjacent and
you'll see that there are no edges
between the two parts labeled with those
two vertices okay so looking at
polymorphisms of partitions of a graph
what do we know about homomorphisms
we've known for quite some time that
there's a dichotomy for counting
homomorphisms to a fixed graph H so
depending on the structure of your fixed
graph H either you can count the number
of hama morphisms from your input graph
to h in polynomial time or its number P
complete when is it easy when is it hard
well in every component of H is a click
with a self loop on every vertex then
the problem becomes trivial you can just
map any vertex of GE to any vertex of
age and all the edges that you could
possibly need to be present our present
so you're allowed whatever edges you
want G alternatively if H is a complete
bipartite graph how can we count
homomorphisms from some graph G into a
complete bipartite graph well firstly if
G is not itself bipartite then the
answer is going to be zero we can never
have a homomorphism from an odd cycle
into a bipartite graph because a
homomorphism to a bipartite graph in
juices are two colouring
on the other hand because our target
graph H is complete excuse me there's
essentially no other restriction hey
we've got a bipartite graph G we need to
map it into H well our choice is either
to map the left part of G to the left
part of H and those vertices on the left
can go anywhere we want on the left
alternatively we map the left part of G
onto the right part of H so we end up
with two possible ways of doing it times
all the ways we can choose a vertex
within the gifts so
and this then actually we can power up
to being not just H being a single
component but looking at all the
components and as long as every single
component as of one of these two forms
you can have a mixture of the two
mixture of loopy clicks and unloop bike
leaks as long as those are the only
components you have counting
homomorphisms to this graph it's going
to be easy using these near trivial
algorithms that I've already described
otherwise it's number P complete okay
and another way we can look at
homomorphisms is as constraint
satisfaction problems so constraint
satisfaction problems we have a bunch of
variables we want to assign values from
some domain to these variables in a way
that satisfies a given list of
constraints so to define a graph on a
morphism problem as a constraint
language as a constraint satisfaction
problem well what are we trying to do
we're trying to map vertices of G two
vertices of H so the domain the things
that we map the variables to is the
vertex of the graph H and then our
constraints are that every time we've
got an edge in our graph G that must be
mapped to an edge in the graph H so if R
is the edge relation H we just slap a
constraint on between any two adjacent
vertices in chief ok so any a morphism
problem corresponds directly to a
constraint satisfaction problem with a
single binary relation
okay so I'm going to generalize from
home offers and problems to matrix
politicians and matrix partitions are
defined by symmetric k by k matrices
where every entry of your matrix is
either a 0 a 1 or a style and a
partition of a graph according to this
matrix is a partition of its vertex set
into a one set for each row or if you
like column of the matrix and we have
the following properties so if the IJ
entry of the matrix is 0 were not
allowed to have any edges from the I
part of the partition into the J part
okay alternatively if so this
corresponds exactly to the case with
homomorphisms okay where there was no
edge in the target graph of homomorphism
we weren't allowed to have any edges
between the partition corresponding to
the end points of verbiage what we're
adding is this middle point if we've got
a one in the matrix in position I J that
means that now it's obligatory to have
edges so in homomorphisms it was never
obligatory to have edges it could be
obligatory to have no edges but now
we've got four stages so if the IJ
element of the matrix is a 1 then there
must be every possible edge between
vertices in part I and vertices in pot J
and stars as is common the case just
mean that we don't care okay so if
there's a star in the matrix you can
have any pattern of edges you like
between the two parts of the partition
this is what happens if I enjoy a
distinct if I enjoy the same well if
we've got a zero on the diagonal of the
matrix that just corresponds meant to
the part being an independent set so
we're not allowed to have any edges
within it if we've got a one on the
diagonal of the matrix that corresponds
to a click we don't force loops on on
each individual vertex but we say that
for every pair of distinct vertices in
that part that must be an edge between
them so if if we've got a one in the
matrix the corresponding part of the
partition must be a clique and if we've
got a star on the diagonal which i
haven't mentioned here then again we
just don't care what the edge structure
is within the i'th part of the partition
okay and as I alluded to a moment ago
homomorphism problems are exactly these
matrix partition problems where your
matrix doesn't have any ones in it okay
so a couple of examples um start with
something familiar and then move on to
things you might not have seen so three
colorings what's a three coloring of a
graph well it's a division of the
vertices of the graph into three parts
the colors we're not allowed to have any
edges between vertices of the same color
so that means that each diagonal entry
of our matrix is going to be zero to
forbid edges with a particular within
each color but on the other hand we
don't care if there are edges or no
edges between green vertices and blue
vertices for example so every other
matrix but every other entry of the
matrix as a style and of course this is
a homomorphism problem it's just home or
more fizzles to a triangle okay another
example a thing called a split graph so
a split graph is a graph where you can
divide the vertex set excuse me into a
click and an independent set and nothing
else okay so any vertex that's placed in
in the first part must be part of a
click any vertex that's placed in the
second part must be part of an
independent set and we don't care what
edges run between this clique and the
independent set as long as we can split
the graph into
and not just that this um isn't a
homomorphism problem we've got zeros and
ones in the matrix another example that
isn't a homomorphism problem are things
called pleat cut sets click cut sets do
pretty much what you'd expect them to do
it's a click that's also a cut-set okay
so we got we're dividing our graph into
three parts one two three the second
part is going to be a click so we'll put
a one on the diagonal that the other two
parts well they're just two parts of the
graph we're not requiring anything
specific about those two parts of the
graph they can have edges or no edges or
you know some combination of the two
however we please so they both come out
of stars we also don't have any
restriction on how each of the
components outside the concert is
connected to the concert okay there
could be some edges between them they
might not be any edges between them but
on the other hand because it's a cut-set
deleting it is supposed to cut the graph
into so there better be no edges from
part one across the part 2 part 3 okay
so we'll say that this says there are no
edges from part 1 2 part 3 and this says
there are no edges and me
okay I don't want to divert you with it
principal you could add another barrier
to the mast external condition that at
least one edge yes yes and you could
generalize it I think people have
considered the case where instead of
saying that zero means no edges at all
you could interpret zero is meaning the
graph is somehow stars and likewise one
is meaning the ref is somehow dense for
whatever definition of sparse and
answers is making sense and working that
would mess up what I'm about to say now
so we'll go back to sports meaning super
sparse no edges at all and dense meaning
every possible action okay so it turns
out that we can also encode these matrix
partition problems as constraint
satisfaction problems our domain is just
the indices of the matrix so we're
assigning 2k different partitions and
our domain is going to be you know the
identities of those partitions we will
have two binary relations one of which
corresponds to the places where you're
allowed to have an edge okay either
because you're forced to have an edge by
a one or you're allowed to have an edge
by a star the other relation will
correspond to the places where you're
allowed to have no edge either you're
forced to have no edge because there's a
zero or you're allowed to have no edge
because there's a stuff
okay and we can code the partition
problem for a fixed matrix am as a
constraint satisfaction problem with
this fixed constraint language the
variables again are just divert the
vertices of the graph that we're trying
to partition and now we have two
collections of constraints for every
edge in the graph that edge you'd better
go somewhere where where we are allowed
to have an edge and for every non edge
of the graph that non edge had better
fall somewhere where we're allowed to
not have an edge ok so we can express
this quite happily as a constraint
satisfaction problem now we know how to
salt constraint satisfaction problems
hey we know that for every constraint
language either you can solve instances
of this in polynomial time or you can
solve or trying to solve these instances
is not be complete and we have an
algorithm in mp to decide which of these
two is the case given a specific
constraint language so if we can code
matrix partition problems as constraint
satisfaction problems and we already
understand the constraint satisfaction
problem I guess that's the end of the
talk of course there is a problem here
this refers to the complexity of
deciding general instances of the
constraint satisfaction problem and if
we look back here the instances here
have a very specific form ok and the
specific form that we have is that for
every pair of vertices or every pair of
variables there is either an R plus
constraint between those foot between
those variables all those an hour-
constraint in particular there's not
both and we don't have any pair of
variables with no constraints at all
between them ok so
see that these here refers to the
opposite case it's possible but for the
constraint language that we've defined
described maybe there are instances or a
class of instances where it's number P
hard to count the satisfying assignments
on the other hand maybe those instances
don't look like the instances that we
have okay so it's perfectly possible
that the instances that come out of em
partitions problems are of somehow
intermediate complexity okay if you
allowed arbitrary instances there'd be
really hard ones but because we
forbidden those instances maybe we end
up with something in the middle so the
CSP dichotomy doesn't actually resolve
the complexity of matrix partitions even
though we can express matrix partitions
as a CSP
okay so if we are going to well which we
are going to try to resolve the the
complexity of this
we're actually going to look at a
slightly different version of the
problem where we add lists to all of the
vertices so you come across list
versions of many problems list colorings
list list H colorings or less
homomorphism problems what the list does
is instead of looking at for example
general colorings each vertex of your
graph will will come with a list of
colors that you're allowed to apply to
that particular vertex okay so you might
only be allowed to color a particular
vertex green or red for example and not
color that one blue okay so now our
instance of the problem is going to be a
graph G we've got a fixed matrix an hour
input will be a graph G and a list
function lambda which for each vertex of
the graph tells you which part which
part of the partition you're allowed to
put that first exit ok and the question
then is how many M partitions Arthur of
the graph would obey the restrictions
given by the list ok so where every
vertex is placed in a part that is in
the list given to that vertex and if we
have a partition of that form we say
that respects the lists
so most of the work that's been done on
this problem has actually been on the
list version the advantage of the lists
is that it allows us to perform
reductions in many cases by forcing
particular vertices of the graph to go
into particular partitions particular
parts of the list partition of the
matrix partners
so what's known so this is the decision
version of the problem for any fixed
matrix M again symmetric 01 star matrix
the complexity of deciding if there
exists at least one listing part at
least one list matrix partition is a
quazy polynomial or NP complete
depending on the precise structure of
the matrix the the formulation here is
actually done in terms of a CSP that
looks very much like this one
hey and what I'm going to talk about is
counting these partitions okay so now we
find that although we couldn't deduce
this from the CSP dichotomy the result
looks actually a lot like the CSP
dichotomy in the sense that for any
fixed matrix counting the list
partitions of some graph is either
doable in polynomial time or its number
P complete pro tip when designing
terminology don't choose something with
nine syllables and then volunteer to
give a talk where you're going to have
to say 150 times but the dichotomy
criterion is the existence of this thing
called a d rectangular rising sequence
first time as i say i would say d
rectangular raising sequence many times
in this talk okay so if you have one of
these things then it is hard to count
the list matrix partitions and if you
have none of these things then there is
a polynomial time algorithm in contrast
to the case of counting homomorphisms so
firstly the dichotomy criterion has a
much fancier word I mean is rather more
complicated to describe not just because
of the choice of terminology and also
unlike the case for homomorphisms
actually the algorithm for counting the
polynomial time cases is somewhat more
involved
okay and also we're not completely tied
to lists some work has been done on the
problem problem without lists for small
matrices so the decision version is
known to be polynomial time or NP
complete the criterion there is
essentially if free coloring is hiding
inside your matrix then guess what it's
NP complete the interesting part is that
if free coloring isn't hiding inside
your matrix then it turns out that
there's a polynomial time algorithm and
so that's the decision for counting
there is again a dichotomy for matrices
of size up to 4 by 4 which is not I
think actually this is four by four as
well for the decision version which
isn't the biggest matrix you'll ever see
actually I think the techniques we used
here could kind of be pushed to five by
five but probably wouldn't be worth the
effort and the criterion actually here
is exactly the same as it is in the list
case he'll Herman and Avicii didn't
prove it in those terms but actually it
does correspond to exactly the same
thing as having one of these D
rectangular izing sequences three times
it turns out that one of these sequences
in a three by three matrix can't
actually be terribly complicated which
is how the hell Herman and a veces
criterion ends up being the same as ours
okay so how are we going to prove this
dichotomy so we proved it by first of
all parameterizing the problem in terms
of what lists you're allowed to use so
we'll define the problem number of L M
partitions where L now is a set of
allowable lists is the same as the M
part of the list and partitions problem
but now as well as having lists that
restrict what each vertex can do well
somebody comes in and restricts what
lists you're allowed to use as well okay
so you're given a set of lists and
you're only allowed to apply those lists
to the vertices on the other hand of
course we can recover the general list
partitions problem just by allowing any
list as part of our so-called
restoration and now on I seem to a
switch notation halfway through my talk
having previously referred to the parts
of the of the thing as one up to k now
i'm going to start calling that set d
okay so one of the properties that will
need and use a lot is a thing called
purity so we will refer to a matrix as
being pure if either it's a zero-star
matrix or it's a one-star matrix okay so
it's either a matrix with no one's or
matrix with no zeros these are matrices
that we understood understand well we
understood before starting because
they're homomorphism problems if they've
got no one's and if they've got no zeros
it's essentially a homomorphism problem
between the complement of the graph that
you thought you were interested in okay
so pure matrix is essentially just a
homomorphism problem will say that our
set of allowable lists is purifying if
whenever you take two elements so two of
your allowed lists and you restrict to
the Rose defined by one of those lists
and the columns defined by the other
then you get a pure matrix okay so as an
example if we take the cleat cut site
matrix and we only allow ourselves these
two lists so this list if you apply it
to a vertex as this vertex must be in
Potter in part two so it must be part of
the clique and this list says it must
not be perfectly okay so if we applied
these two lists firstly if we apply just
the list too then we're cutting down to
this one by one matrix in the middle
which is a pure matrix it's not no zeros
in it
alternatively if we look at rows one and
three and column two then we get the
matrix with the two red stars in it
which is also pure it's got no zeros in
it for example or alternatively we might
restrict to the rows and columns given
by one and three and then we get the
matrix given by the red points around
the edge which again is pure ok so this
list is purifying but on the other hand
if we said for example 1 and 2 2 and 3
then we'd be restricting to this 4 by 4
matrix matrix in the corner this is not
pure
so trying to define the dread d
rectangular izing sequence I'm going to
define for any subsets of the domain and
these subsets are naturally going to
correspond to lists but for now I'll
define it for anything at all so for any
subset of the domain subsets x and y the
domain r XY is just the relation that
you get from the positions of the stars
within the sub matrix / x and y ok so
that gives us a binary relation on two
subsets of the domain I'm going to
define a sequence of subsets of the
domain again as being d rectangular
arising if first of all every pair of
these sets when you restrict the rows
and the columns using those person sets
you always end up with a pure matrix ok
so this list of lists of sat's is
purifying and also when we compose all
of these relations so the relation that
you get from the first to and from the
second two and the third two and so on
take all of those relations compose them
together
if the result is not rectangular than
this sequences d rectangular Isaac okay
so you can see how we kind of railroaded
ourselves into this bad now what is
rectangular mean um rectangular just
means that whenever we have these three
components in our relation so x 1 y 1 x
1 y 2 and also x2 y1 then we've got to
have the fourth corner of the rectangle
so if we just go back here this relation
here the two by two is rectangular
because we don't have stars on three of
the four corners the relation defined by
this two by two sub matrix on the other
hand is not rectangular because it has
three of the four corners of the
rectangle but not the fourth this
there's two by two matrix by the way
corresponds to counting clicks yeah
that's a partition or into a click and
anything you like and you don't care
what edges there are between the two so
this two by two matrix corresponds to
counting clicks and you'd expect that to
be hard okay thank you probably know
that it's okay
so moving towards proving the dichotomy
the first case we'll look at is where
the lists that were allowed to use are
purified okay so the list that we've
been given break up the matrix into
these pure sub matrices that correspond
to on a morphism it turns out that if we
are purifying then the matrix partitions
problem is in fact equivalent to a CSP
it's not just that you can translate to
a CSP in one direction is that in a
sense every instance of that CSP does
correspond to a matrix partitions
problem so actually that will give us
the dichotomy for um for the purifying
case we also require our set of allowed
lists to be subject closed okay so if
you if a particular list is allowed all
of its subsets must also be allowed the
reason for that is that as we process
the the instance we want to start
restricting the list applied to any
particular vertex making it smaller and
smaller and we want all of those lists
to be available to us
so
this is the dichotomy um that we get
okay so this is the dichotomy that we
get for the restricted list problem
where the list that we're allowed are
purifying so if we have a d rectangular
izing sequence then at some poppy
complete addy rectangular izing sequence
contained within the allowable lists
otherwise it's in polynomial time so
I'll go through a bit of the proof of
that and then give some hints at how
you'd prove the general case where your
lists are not purifying ok so this I've
already mentioned implicitly if you flip
the zeroes and ones and the matrix um
this is equivalent to flipping edges and
non edges ok so counting matrix
partitions of a graph is exactly the
same thing as counting the complimentary
matrix partitions of the complimentary
graph ok and this is the thing that
actually allows us to translate
purifying instances in to and back from
constraint satisfaction problems
and so what the translation there does
slide about that I do okay um so if you
look at the list applied to
so we've got vertices are v1 and v2 with
lists l1 and l2 now because the list
that we're allowed to use are purifying
we know that the matrix between l1 and
l2 is either a zero-star matrix in which
case it's a homomorphism problem or it's
a one star matrix in which case it's
kind of a complementary homomorphism
problem well according to which it is um
we can either add the constraint of one
kind or the other and paste all of these
things together boundaries to get um
which one am I going sorry so we
translate from the list matrix partition
problem to the CSP problem in exactly
the way I told you earlier the question
is how do we translate from a CSP back
to a matrix partition problem so you're
given a CSP problem and you need to
produce a graph whose matrix partitions
correspond to the solutions to the CSP
ok so if we have the relation between
these that corresponds to a homomorphism
problem then we add the edge if we have
a relation corresponding to a
complementary homomorphism problem then
we have no edge and it turns out that
when we paste all of those together we
end up with a graph that's perfectly
well defined and whose number of em
partitions actually corresponds to the
number of solutions to an arbitrary
incoming CSP instance
okay going in the other direction the
definition of D rectangular rising
sequence will have looked familiar to
those of you who are who know the
counting CSP dichotomy because the
counting CSP dichotomy is all based
around can you define some kind of
non-rectangular relation and AD
rectangular rising sequence is just a
particular way of defining a
non-rectangular relation so if we have a
d rectangular izing sequence that
corresponds quite directly to a number p
completeness of the corresponding CSP
instance and because it's a because
these two things are polynomial time
equivalent that gives you a number P
completeness of the matrix partitions
problem okay
now then the question is okay I've told
you roughly how things work when the
lists that were allowed a purifying but
of course restricting to only being
allowed particular lists was just a tool
that we use to get the proof go through
so in particular we want this to work if
you're allowed the set of all possible
lists and the only way that the set of
all possible lists can be purifying well
that just says that every sub matrix of
your matrix is pure well that just says
the matrix is pure so we've only solved
the general problem for homomorphism
problems which didn't need to be solved
because we already knew the answer okay
so what do we do if the lists that we've
been given allow us access to non-pure
sub matrices of our matrix what we do is
we purify so we take our impure lists
and we can track them down to get lists
which in fact are purifying and then
combine the answers that we get from
these so what do we do we're given a
graph G and an assignment of lists to
each of the vertices what we do is we
compute several list functions lambda 1
up to lambda T and they have the
following property so first of all each
of these lambdas is purifying ok so we
originally had a single instance with a
single list function what will now do is
give multiple lists functions
and for each vertex and each one of
these new list functions the we've only
ever made let the arrow on Osiris for
every vertex each of the lists are
signed by these functions is a subset of
the lists assigned by the original
function and the goal of all of this is
that every matrix partition of the
original graph well of the graph we're
not going to change the graph that
respects the original lists respects
exactly one of the new lists okay so if
you like we've partitioned the
partitions into a bunch of purifying
instances where now if we just add up
the number of partitions for each of
those instances we get the answer that
we were looking for okay and it turns
out that this purification algorithm
does run in polynomial time as long as
there's no D rectangular rising sequence
and in fact as long as there's no length
to D rectangular izing sequence
available in this case we're not even
worried about the possibility of longer
ones
okay so by transforming everything into
pure instances we can then use the CSP
techniques from before to solve them and
we get our dichotomy that if you have
one of these d rectangular rising
sequences available to you then counting
the partitions is in is not be complete
otherwise we have a polynomial time
algorithm going via csps now see I
haven't mentioned it yet but we we use
our consistency to solve those CSP
instances I pretty much at the end so I
think I'll stop there like so you may be
expecting this question would it be
possible to generalize this to the to an
asymmetric case um yeah it certainly
makes sense to do that what makes me
think that there might not be any so and
I was thinking of doing it myself what
makes me think it might not actually be
so interesting is that this condition of
empty rectangular izing sequences it
just doesn't care whether or not the
graph is directed because you're looking
at arbitrary sub matrices not even you
know principles of matrices so kind of
the subproblems are already slightly
undirected so it's not obvious that
anything would happen or at least it's
not obvious that you'd get a different
criterion
yeah would you expect the answer for
listless version to be the same depends
what day of the week US mail I'm
honestly not sure so for up to four by
four it is the same but it's it's hard
to say whether it would be or not I
think between those of us who are
looking at it we conjectured it yeah but
now i'm not sure that i believe the
conjecture is true but i can't give you
any good reason for that
just some terminology and Albert Meyer
used to say in his papers conjecture
when he thought it was true and strike
injector what he knew was screwed I
think it's fair to say that we thought
it was true when we wrote it and call it
a conjecture yeah well there was not a
strong conjecture now I now I think it
might be a question where the answer is
maybe yes rather than a conjecture I'm
not sure it's not true um yeah you see
then someone says that and it seems that
you know obviously the conjecture is
true yeah I've no idea